so the question is where did the
standard American diet come from the
standard American diet was nothing more
than the solution to a business problem
the standard American diet is what is
killing people
[Music]
hello everyone today I'm speaking with
physician longevity expert and now
author Dr Peter Adia we discussed this
new book outlive the science and art of
longevity and explore the immense
benefits that can be gained from
exercise in just three hours a week how
small imbalances in diet can cause major
problems such as diabetes and obesity
the difference between lifespan and
health span the soured reasoning behind
the American food pyramid
and the scientific side of alternative
diets no buzzwords
looking forward to the discussion today
Dr Adia in your book you talk about
lifespan in general but you also
concentrate it on a concept
called Health span termed Health span
and you're concentrating more on decades
let's say of healthy life rather than
absolute length of Life do you want to
expand on the concept of Health span and
why you distinguish between that and
Longevity per se yeah longevity is
really a function of lifespan and health
span so lifespan is the easier of those
two to understand because it's binary
you're either alive or you're dead and I
think when most people think of
longevity they think of the elongation
of lifespan understandably but you know
that's really only part of it the other
part uh the part that might actually be
more important to most people when
pressed on the issue is Health span
which is the quality of life and the
medical definition of Health span is not
a particularly helpful definition in my
view it's effectively the period of time
from which you are free of disability
and disease but I don't really think
that captures what health span is to
most people and so I think Health band
is is a broader concept and it's not
binary it is analog but it really
constitutes some measure of cognitive
health physical health and emotional
health and at least two of those are
intimately linked to age which is to say
they generally decline with age
um but if we focus I think relentlessly
on the pursuit of those things we tend
to get a better quality of life overall
and by the way I think you get for free
a lot of lifespan benefits right so well
it's very important to get the
definitions and the measurements right
because systems optimize to maximize
their score on what they're measured by
and I suppose living to 140 wouldn't be
so good if you were senile for the last
70 years and institutionalized for
example and so it sounds like when you
talk about health span you're
intermingling to
uh what would you say to Quality of Life
issues one would be the expansion of
Youth rather than longevity per se and
then something associated with
the existential quality of life so maybe
we could start with well
does does that seem to capture the the
interaction of those two things seem to
capture what you're talking about with
regard to health span yeah I think so I
think that the cognitive and physical
piece are the pieces that do decline
with age and we want to preserve those
as long as possible and we can be very
specific about what those things are by
the way right we could drill into what
is cognitive Health span what is
physical health span and then that other
one that is not so age dependent might
be at least as important uh and probably
frankly Falls much more into your
wheelhouse than mine professionally at
least and that is about the quality of a
person's life and the quality of their
relationships their sense of purpose and
things of that nature
the content I've created over the past
year represents some of my best to date
as I've undertaken additional extensive
exploration in today's most challenging
topics and experienced a nice increment
in production quality courtesy of daily
wire plus we all want you to benefit
from the knowledge gained throughout
this adventurous Journey I'm pleased to
let you know that for a limited time
you're invited to access all my content
with a seven day free trial at dailywire
plus this will provide you with full
access to my new In-Depth series on
marriage as well as guidance for
creating a Life vision and my series
exploring the book of Exodus you'll also
find there the complete library of all
my podcasts and lectures I have a
plethora of new content in development
that will be coming soon exclusively on
daily wire plus voices of reason and
resistance are few and far between these
strange days click on the link below if
you want to learn more and thank you for
watching and listening
thank you
[Music]
yeah so a long while back I was looking
at interventions
to improve people's lives and I knew at
that point that cognitive decline was a
major problem especially in terms of
well productivity and uh and and general
competence and so
it's pretty pronounced linear downhill
trend on the fluid intelligence front
from about the age of 25 forward and
that can decline precipitously in say
late 70s early 80s especially with the
onset of degenerative neurological
diseases and I was looking at the
literature on cognitive remediation this
is back in the times
about 10 15 years ago when there were a
lot of online sites that purported to
run you through cognitive exercises that
could increase or maintain your IQ
there's never been any evidence for that
by the way it's a pretty damn dismal
literature but I what I did find and I
think this is extremely solid is that if
you want to maintain your cognitive
function that both cardiovascular
exercise and weightlifting seem to do a
pretty damn good job and maybe that's
because the brain is such a oxygen
demanding organ uh and other obviously
energy so energy it's energy demanding
and the resource demanding in other ways
and if you can keep yourself
cardiovascularly fit
interestingly enough that's the best
Pathway to cognitive Health then I was
looking on the
psychological side you know
and what I found was that there were
interventions that help people get their
stories straight of course Psychotherapy
is one of those but there are written
interventions
if people write about their past about
their past traumas and if they write
about their future plans they reduce
General uncertainty that reduces their
stress and that seems to produce a
relatively pronounced physiological
benefit and so there's an interesting
interplay there that we can talk about
more in terms of
the emotional and the physical it's
pretty funny that if you want to improve
your cognitive function or maintain it
you should exercise rather than think
and that if you want to improve your
physiology you should straighten out
your story and face your traumas rather
than say exercise so
um
what do you recommend
in your book in outlive in particular
with regard to the expansion of Health
span what do you think and and how do
you practice this personally what do you
recommend to people
so I I think that exercise is
empirically the most valuable tool we
have for both the cognitive and physical
components so let's start with the
cognitive because I think here it was
less intuitive uh so about 10 years ago
when I really went down this Rabbit Hole
I had one of my research analysts uh
spend a lot of time going through the
literature so we created a framework
where we were going to look at every
single intervention and how it impacted
executive function processing speed
short-term memory long-term memory those
were the four metrics we cared about
because as you point out those are all
bits of uh intelligence that decline
with age
so
um and I we looked at everything okay so
we looked at every molecule we looked at
every possible thing that you could
think of
and after about nine months of this the
thing that stood out Above All Else
Beyond any diet beyond the importance of
sleep and other things that certainly
mattered controlling blood pressure
lipids Etc
was exercise and I I even though I was a
lifelong exerciser and love to exercise
I just couldn't believe it it seemed so
trite that exercise could have such a
profound difference on the state of
cognition not just in terms of its
performance is effectively a nootropic
but also in its ability to delay if not
outright prevent dementia
so
once we dug into the mechanisms I think
it became clear why exercise is so
potent and it's basically that it is
acting on so many different levels so as
you pointed out it's acting at a
metabolic level the brain is such an
energy demanding organ as you know and
maybe your listeners do you know it
weighs about two percent of your body
weight and it's responsible for 20 to 25
percent of your energy consumption so
therefore anything that disrupts that is
catastrophic so when you look at the
improvements in glucose disposal insulin
sensitivity and all metabolic parameters
exercise is the most important tool we
have there when you look at the
reduction of inflammation vascular
Health improvements again exercise
stands alone when you look at the
production of neurotropic growth factors
such as bdnf again exercise is basically
a drug for neurons
and so I think I eventually came around
after a year or so to realize that again
as simple as it sounds exercise is such
a potent tool and you look at the brains
of people who exercise a lot
and you can see far less damage not just
microvascularly but in terms of brain
volume loss over time
so
let's talk about exercise from the
perspective of a behavioral psychologist
so one of the things you learn
as a behavioral psychologist is that
it's very difficult for people to
change their attitudes or their actions
and it's very difficult for people to
change their lives and so and we all
know this because we might tell
ourselves for example to exercise
and we might be well supplied with
Arguments for why that's a good idea
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
we learn how to incorporate an exercise
routine into our life and often the
reason for that there's many reasons I
mean exercise is difficult and that's
one reason but
it's also often the case that people
don't form a strategy and break the
problem down into steps that are simple
enough to actually Implement so they
think things like well I'll go to the
gym two hours a day three times a week
and I'll start that next week and truth
of the matter is they don't have six
hours to spend and they can't tell
themselves what to do anyways and so
what you do is a behavioral psychologist
is you look at the simplest possible
change that produces the maximum
possible benefit and so for example if
people are listening and they want to
begin to implement an exercise routine
like what about a daily walk of 10
minutes in the morning like where would
you start someone so it completely
depends on their Baseline but based on
your question Jordan I'm going to take
it as we're talking about someone who's
doing no exercise
um yeah let's start with them yeah so
the good news is first of all
um and I accept the fact that not
everybody is swayed by data but I at
least want to put it out there so if
you're a person who's in the doing zero
exercise per week Camp the very good
news is the benefit you get from going
from zero to three hours a week
is a greater benefit than anyone gets
along the exercise curve right so taking
someone who's at five hours and taking
them to 15 will produce less relative
benefit than going from zero to three so
in other words I want that person to see
some real incentive for making this
change secondly I'll put some numbers to
it right so going from no exercise to
three hours a week
approximately reduces your cause of your
all-cause mortality that is to say death
by every cause
by 50 at any moment in time so if you're
standing there asking what's the
probability I'm going to die this year
well we can sort of actuarially figure
that out
you get to cut that number in half by
simply going from zero to three hours to
exercise a week if you're a
non-exerciser so again there's going to
be a subset of people for whom that's a
very powerful piece of information they
didn't know
so then what I would say was how do you
how do you do that so I agree with you
that you're much better off trying to do
30 minutes
six times a week then three hours once a
day uh or you know two hours you know in
whatever fashion so so what I would say
is the most effective way to do that is
probably about 90 minutes of low
intensity cardio and for a person who's
not particularly fit that's going to
amount to just brisk walking
rather than tell them what to do I tell
them how to feel when they're doing it
so what you want to feel is out of
breath enough that you can barely carry
out a conversation but you could if you
had to
but not so out of breath that you can't
carry on a conversation
and not so easy that you can speak
easily
so there's that sweet spot in there
physiologically we call that zone two
but I'm not going to bore them with that
nomenclature it's just basically 90
minutes say three times thirty or two
times 45 a week where you're just out of
breath enough that you don't want to
talk but you could if you had to
that's part one right so you you push
push yourself past your slightly past
your simple level of comfort that's
right and so let me push on you a bit
with regards to three hours a week um
again from the perspective of taking
someone from zero to to somewhere
um what are the benefits let's say you
talked about the benefits of walking
something approximating 20 to 25 minutes
a day that can be
burst out various ways you also
mentioned like two 45-minute sessions or
three thirty minute sessions if someone
what would happen if someone goes from
zero to like 10 minutes a day or an hour
a week where do that benefits of that
three hours yeah that's a great question
I don't think we have the Fidelity of
the data at that level because you
generally don't push enough of a
conditioning benefit but I think what
you're getting at and we do this as well
is you want to separate between the
behavior change and the physiologic
change
and for some people and James Clear has
written a lot about this but I think a
lot of people have come to the same
conclusion with any Behavior change
if it's a person who's never done
anything you're right the answer might
be for every day when you wake up in the
morning rather than your normal routine
of jumping in front of the computer I
want you to go and walk around the block
once it'll take four minutes
but and so I don't want to represent
you're going to get a physiologic
benefit from that you probably won't but
what you will get is you're going to
start to reset a behavior which is aha
the first thing I do in the morning now
is this other thing and we'll slowly
increase that and at some point you will
get a physiologic benefit but what we're
doing is planting the seed of how to
change the behavior
yeah well if you could always expand
that over a year I mean one of the
things another thing I learned as a
behavioral therapist this seems obvious
but it's not obvious enough so that
people think about it or put it into
practice is that
your life is made up of the very small
number of things that you repeat every
day
and these are often things that people
consider trivial so for example lots of
people sit down to have dinner with
their family every evening and they
don't consider that special but because
you do it every damn day for an hour or
an hour and a half it's like eight
percent of your life so you only have to
get 15 of those things in order and you
have your whole life in order
same thing applies to a daily habit and
so if you started say walking for 10
minutes a day well that's 70 minutes a
week and that's four hours a month or 50
hours or One Work Week a year and that's
a substantive change that's about two
percent of your life's your Waking Life
something like that or at least two
percent of your awake working life and
so these it's useful for everyone
listening to understand that small
changes that you maintain can be of
radical importance and once you're
walking for 10 minutes a day it's a hell
of a lot easier to go to say 12 minutes
than it it is to go from zero to walking
at all
so yeah
so okay okay so let so what do you think
what what what did you conclude as a
consequence of going through the
literature with regards to say uh
weightlifting rather than cardiovascular
exercise
so in biology we look to integral
functions to give us a sense of how
valuable an input is and you don't get
many of them okay so most people are
probably familiar with something called
the hemoglobin A1c
um it's a blood test you get at the
doctor and if it's high enough it tells
you if you have type 2 diabetes so if
the hemoglobin A1c is beyond 6.5 percent
that tells you that over the past three
months your average blood glucose has
been 140 milligrams per deciliter which
is the cutoff for type 2 diabetes so in
that sense hemoglobin A1c is an integral
of your behavior over the past three
months with respect to glucose we don't
have a lot of those but we have two
really amazing ones with respect to
exercise
one of them is around strength and
muscle mass and one of them is around
Peak cardiorespiratory Fitness
with respect to the so I'll just get to
the punch line the punch line is there
is no metric that is more highly
associated with living a long life just
this is purely based on length of life
there's no metric anywhere in the
medical literature that's more highly
correlated with this
than having a high VO2 max VO2 max is a
measure of your Peak cardiorespiratory
Fitness
but the second most highly correlated
metric of length of life
is a composite metric of strength and
muscle mass
so in other words the and why why people
always ask me why is it so important
I think it's important because those
things are remarkable integral functions
yeah so so they basically tell you they
add up the work that has been done to
that point
so you don't just have a VO2 max because
you woke up one day and decided to do
something positive you have a high VO2
max because you've been training very
hard for a long period of time in many
cases for years similarly a person
doesn't just wake up and have a lot of
muscle mass or have a lot of great
strength those things are the product of
a lot of work and I think that's why
they are so potent in fact they are far
more potent as predictors of a long life
than all of the negative things you can
imagine are predictors of a short life
so when you look at things like smoking
type 2 diabetes hypertension even the
presence of cancer has a lesser impact
on the shortness of your life than those
other variables have on the length of
your life
I've read that grip strength for example
is a good marker of propensity for
longevity well in everyone but
particularly in elderly people and it
isn't as you pointed out because grip
strength per se is particularly
important but because grip strength
happens to be a good marker for overall
what would you say psychophysiological
integrities 100 a hundred percent yeah
it's it's grip strength is one of the
most potent so put this way the if you
compare the top decile to the bottom
decile and grip strength it's a 70
difference in incidence and death from
dementia all cause Dimension not just
Alzheimer's every form of dementia
when I was in my mid-20s
when I was 21 22 I weighed about 130
pounds 135 pounds I was six foot one and
so very very thin and I spent about
three years four years intensely
weight lifting and packed on about 35
pounds of muscle I'd eat like a Mad Dog
for about three years to do that but one
of the things I noticed that was really
cool was that I also got to be a lot
more coordinated I was using free
weights you know because free weights
help exercise all the little muscles and
tendons and but I also it also seemed to
me to be unbelievably useful for
facilitating likely for facilitating
nerve myelinization and I thought then
think now that that was probably a good
marker that increase in coordination was
probably a good marker for improved
neurological function
and so yeah and and as and as as you age
um it doesn't get a lot of attention but
sarcopenia which is the loss of muscle
mass the wasting away that occurs with
aging uh and again this begins rather
subtly
um we we lose you know what are called
type 2 muscle fibers first that's the
Hallmark of Aging so the the type of
muscle fiber that's responsible for
explosive power is the first one that
begins to atrophy when we age uh even at
my age I'm 50 I'm already experiencing
that to a great extent I don't have a
fraction of the explosive power I had at
25.
um once you lose explosive strength you
start to lose overall strength and once
you lose that you're going to start to
lose muscle size is the very last thing
so by the time a person is 75 the
decline in muscle size which is already
preceding strength uh is significant
now we can do a lot to prevent this and
I think that that's what's being
captured by these statistics the people
who are able to delay that loss of
strength and muscle mass are the ones
that are going to live the longest on
average
yeah so on the weightlifting front we
talked a little bit about you know what
you could do simply to start working out
on the cardiovascular front and brisk
walking is the simplest and most
straightforwardly implementable
strategy on that front I would add one
thing to that Jordan which is once a
person reaches a certain level of
fitness
the brisk walk may not be sufficient
enough to produce enough cardiovascular
stress depends where you live but if you
live in an area where you've got a lot
of Hills that might not be the case but
for most people
you know there's a there's a limit in
human gait to how fast you can walk and
for most people it's about 3.5 to maybe
up to four miles per hour and again at a
certain point that's not going to be
fast enough so what we can do for that
individual rather than have them
transition to running I like to put
weight on their back called rucking so
you carry a military type of backpack
with plates of weight in the back and
now you without putting additional
stress on the knees put additional
stress on the cardiorespiratory system
so just throw that out there as
additional ways to to get this done
yeah well I okay okay
um as I said in my 20s I worked out with
free weights and
um I have an adjust set of adjustable
free weights now but what what I found
very straightforward naturally
implementable is to use
about I use about 20 25 pound weights
depending on how often I'm doing it and
run through uh I run through a set of
exercises through my whole body you know
starting with my calves and moving
upward and I can do a whole workout
routine it's about two sets of 15
exercises in about 20 minutes
and so for everyone listening it's also
very simple to use to start
weightlifting because all you need is a
couple of dumbbells size is going to
depend on you know your size and your
strength but you can do an awful lot
with with two dumbbells you can exercise
your body in all sorts of ways so that
combined with walking and you add
another twist to that that's not a bad
initiation
yeah I think the other thing that I
would say and I think about this stuff
all the time so I I have a very
elaborate gym I do you know every sort
of exercise you can imagine but
sometimes I like thinking and debating
with people like what's the single most
important exercise you could do if you
could only do one and for the lower body
right for the lower body I think step
UPS would be so if you had just two
dumbbells and a box
you can do anything right because you're
going to do forward Step Up backwards
step up side step up you can go heavy
you can go light you focus on the
concentric phase which is the the phase
of getting up concentric is the phase of
a muscle when it's getting shorter but
then you really get to focus on how
slowly you can step down so my typical
I'm doing box step ups at least twice a
week
um I do a count of one up three down so
taking three full seconds on that one
leg to descend and that's training what
we think of as the brakes so when we age
this is a particular form of strength
that deteriorates which is eccentric
strength the strength that a muscle
exhibits while it is getting longer
this is why so many old people fall and
the mortality of a fall when you are
above the age of 65 is staggering so
depending on the series you look at 15
to 30 percent of people over the age of
65 who fall and break a hip will be dead
within a year of that fall of those who
survive 50 percent of them will
experience a reduction in class of
Mobility so meaning people who walked
normally will walk with a cane people
who walk with a cane will walk with a
walker people who walk with a walker
will be a wheelchair bound this is a
profound change in quality of life and a
lot of it has to do with a loss of this
type of strength if you think about it
people are much more likely to hurt
themselves stepping off a curb when they
get old than stepping onto a curb it's
this it's these loss of breaks so uh
yeah a set of dumbbells which you can
carry around because that's really a
very important piece of upper body
strength is being able to carry
something that's where that grip
strength is coming from and being able
to do step UPS step Downs
squats all sorts of things uh yeah you
don't you don't want to let perfect be
the enemy of good when it comes to
initiating this type of thing
how how how high does the box work can
you use steps yeah so I think a box is
superior
um what you want to be able to do is
work up to a height such that when the
foot is on the box the front leg is on
the box the thigh is parallel to the
ground so for most people that's
16 inches maybe 18 inches a very tall
person might be 20 inches I recommend
people start at a 12 inch step
um until they you know sort of and you
start with your body weight let's be
clear I mean for many people just doing
a proper step up and step down with body
weight at 12 inches is right and
actually
in the book I it was becoming so
difficult to write about this in detail
that I did there's a whole section where
I write about how to do this but in the
end we created a thing on our website
where I just have a bunch of videos
where I illustrate these things so in
the book it directs people to where to
go to just see I think eight or nine
videos of the most important exercises
that I think people should be able to do
well we should put that in the video
description so we'll have to remember to
do that yeah all right let's let's uh
segue if you don't mind to
nutrition and diet and we can talk about
obesity diabetes and inflammation on
that front let I I was interested in
your comments on Diabetes so my
understanding
and this is entangled with the problem
of obesity
my understanding is that when Physicians
test for blood sugar
they age adjust the norms
and that strikes me as let's say
peculiar because
it seems
self-evident that
if you have normal
levels of blood sugar at 40 but that
would make you diabetic or pre-diabetic
at 20 then you're actually diabetic or
pre-diabetic and what that implies is
that the rate of diabetes which is
already
ridiculously and preposterously and
devastatingly high is actually much
higher than we think so
correct me if I'm wrong or elaborate on
that if you would if you think I'm on to
something there so we don't do that I
can't speak to what any other physician
does but in our practice uh we hold
everybody to the same standard I think
we will acknowledge on one metric
because we use a standardized dose of
glucose when we do what's called an oral
glucose tolerance test we will give
women a little bit more latitude because
they don't have as much muscle mass so
there's a particular test that we do
where we give people 75 grams of glucose
and we time at 30 60 90 120 Minutes what
their glucose and insulin level is and
in that window of time what you are
testing is how efficiently do their
muscles take up glucose that's called
glucose disposal so you're measuring
insulin sensitivity and glucose disposal
and in in that window of time that's the
only place you can put the excess
glucose and
um because women have less muscle than
men we will tolerate a slightly higher
glucose response but we want the same
insulin response so that's it's and it's
a very subtle difference
um but no we do we don't age adjust for
anybody we we sort of we want a 60 year
old to be as effective at this as a 30
year old
whether you're feeling stressed anxious
or simply seeking a moment of peace and
Tranquility the Hallow app has something
for you hallo offers an incredible range
of guided meditations and prayers that
are designed to help you deepen your
spirituality and strengthen your
connection to God with hallow you can
explore different themes and types of
prayer and meditation such as gratitude
forgiveness and centering prayer you can
also choose from different lengths of
meditation to fit your schedule whether
you have a few minutes or an hour with
this user-friendly interface and
hundreds of guided meditations the
Hallow app has quickly become a go-to
resource for people seeking spiritual
growth and healing download the app for
free at halo.com Jordan you can set
prayer reminders and track your progress
along the way hallow is truly
transformative and will help you connect
with your faith on a deeper level so
what are you waiting for download the
Hallow app today at hallow.com Jordan
that's hallow.com Jordan once again it's
hello.com Jordan for an exclusive
three-month free trial of all six
thousand plus prayers and meditations
so can you outline for people what
happens during normal Western aging
let's say on the insulin and glucose
metabolism front and and what that
implies for age-related degenerative
diseases
it's a very interesting thing and we're
not entirely clear why but there is an
unmistakable decline in insulin
sensitivity as a person ages
now it doesn't mean that you're destined
to have insulin resistance or fatty
liver disease or type 2 diabetes when
you age but what it generally means is
on average a person needs to be more
diligent as they age
and I've Heard lots of theories offered
for this and my guess is they all play a
role there's clearly a reduction in
testosterone as we age testosterone is a
very
pro-medabolic health hormone right so
testosterone promotes lipolysis of fat
by muscle it's an IT promotes insulin
sensitivity in fact there was a a
clinical trial about a year and a half
ago that looked at men without type 2
diabetes but who were pre-diabetic on
and off testosterone replacement therapy
and you showed a significant reduction
in the progression to type 2 diabetes in
men on testosterone so clearly the
decline of testosterone is playing a
role in both men and women by the way
um we also see less expression uh or or
less uh activity of an enzyme called
lipoprotein lipase LPL where it shifts
more of its uh activity from muscle to
Fat this is again an enzyme that is
responsible for the breakdown of fat
[Music]
um
there are also other things as you
pointed out such as inflammation that
increases with aging
um
we also tend to be less active as we age
and the one of the most important things
to preserve insulin sensitivity is
activity so there's a really famous
researcher at Yale named Jerry Shulman
who's one of the world's Authorities on
the etiology of insulin resistance
and when he does clinical trials when he
does experiments on human subjects at
Yale
and he wants to study insulin resistance
the one criteria he must have
that the subjects can't be physically
active
so in other words for him to figure out
what insulin resistance looks like even
in a 20 year old he has to ensure that
they are not exercising at all
so it's some combination of these things
and probably some other things that are
explaining why all of us have to work
harder as we age to avoid this phenotype
so maybe you could Define insulin
resistance describe its relationship to
elevated blood sugar or to blood sugar
in general and then discuss the
relationship between the elevated blood
sugar insulin resistance and and aging
as such
so
think of the muscle uh maybe as a
balloon and the balloon is the only
place where you can put air and this
analogy air is the glucose
so
there are some balloons that are very
easy to blow up
and you you know you can put the glucose
into the muscle cell you can put the air
into the balloon quite easily you don't
have to blow very hard
but imagine a balloon that's very very
difficult to put air into
and at some point you can get air into
it but you have to blow much harder so
the how hard you have to blow is the
amount of insulin you need to put the
glucose into the muscle at some point
you will not be able to do that you
can't blow hard enough
so again just thinking about this in
terms of physiology glucose
is a molecule that needs to be regulated
very carefully in our in our bodies too
much and too little is catastrophic and
so the body does a great job of trying
to take excess glucose out of the
circulation and put it into muscle cells
by the way just to put this in context
Jordan a healthy person has about one
teaspoon of glucose floating around all
of their circulation at any moment in
time
person with one teaspoon one teaspoon a
person with Frank diabetes has two
teaspoons
that's the difference between healthy
and nearly dying right it's profound how
many teaspoons of sugar are in a bottle
of coke it's 30 I think or 35 uh about
eight about eight teaspoons in a small I
guess I was thinking of a big maybe I
was thinking in a big two liter in a big
two liter it would probably be about
that yeah yeah right so so our body is
amazing at doing this but it's a very
delicate dance between how much insulin
do you need to make that happen and the
the canary in the coal mine of insulin
resistance is after a person is
challenged with glucose even if their
glucose levels normalize they needed
supranormal levels of insulin to do it
that's the initial blowing too hard on
the balloon
so when you develop insulin resistance
and that progresses to diabetes you
literally can't produce enough insulin
to get sugar into the muscles that's
correct eventually you cannot make
enough insulin and this is Complicated
by another factor which ties into this
Cascade of metabolic disease which is
eventually fat starts spilling out from
the cells that we are meant to use to
store excess energy which are our actual
subcutaneous fat cells and that fat
starts spilling into other areas where
we're not supposed to have it into the
muscle which is what's causing the
actual mechanism of insulin resistance
it's the fat in the muscle that is
preventing the insulin signal from being
heard effectively by the muscle cell it
also expands into the liver that's what
that's what's called fatty liver disease
or non-alcoholic fatty liver disease the
fat starts to be deposited in the
pancreas where insulin is made and that
creates an inflammatory environment to
the insulin-producing cells so now you
have the double whammy you need more
insulin but you can make less of it
because of the inflammation and this
thing very quickly spirals out of
control and the end state is type 2
diabetes
so now you have two teaspoons of sugar
in your blood instead of one teaspoon
and so what are the consequences of that
excess sugar load which in absolute uh
amount seems very trivial right I mean
one teaspoon in all of your blood seems
like almost nothing and two doesn't seem
like much either but the difference is
at two teaspoons the difference is
starting to tip you towards towards what
sort of so you have two problems going
on now you have too much glucose and too
much insulin because remember when you
have that high level of glucose you're
going to be treated with drugs that aim
to increase insulin and that can
sometimes be insulin itself or it could
be drugs that produce more insulin
so let's start with the glucose side of
the equation
the easiest way I think to think about
this is too much glucose is bad for
small blood vessels
too much insulin is bad for large blood
vessels so what are those small blood
vessels the very first place this shows
up is looking right into the eye
so I've always believed that a good
ophthalmologist will spot metabolic
disease before any doctor will because
when they can look into the retinal
artery and see the earliest indication
of microvascular occlusion and
inflammation that is tied directly to
What's called the glycosylation so
glucose sticking to proteins including
hemoglobin in the blood that's basically
creating microscopic what we call
ischemia or lack of blood flow to the
most distal perfused organs so other
small vessels that are absolutely
ravaged by glucose or the kidneys so
diabetes along with hypertension would
be the most common driver of end-stage
kidney disease you also see it in the
coronary arteries and believe it or not
it's probably one of the most important
physiologic drivers of erectile
dysfunction again very small blood
vessels in the penis and therefore when
these things succumb to this type of
end-stage glycosylation you're going to
see damage all around
conversely on the insulin side elevated
levels of insulin chronically it's a
pro-growth factor so it's very likely
the explanation for why obesity is the
second leading environmental contributor
to cancer after smoking
and it also damages large and
medium-sized blood vessels like the
aorta the carotid arteries Etc
so this Cascade of again it doesn't
sound like much of a difference as you
said
um it's a it's a chronic issue that over
enough time leads to the destruction of
most tissues
so can you lay out the relationship now
between insulin resistance excess blood
sugar and the propagation of of fat
tissue
now the fat is being used to store
energy but how does that actually occur
and how is that related to excess sugar
yeah so so in many ways uh we were doing
really well as a species until
you know 100 years ago right in that you
know what allowed us to have this
remarkable escape from all other species
vis-a-vis natural selection was this
ability to store energy and fuel our
brains so as we talked about earlier
like the brain is such an energy
demanding organ that we couldn't have
survived if we
we didn't have a way to keep energy
portable with us uh we you know how
would we survive a day with no food if
we didn't have a way to store energy
because certainly more than one day you
have to use fat stores to get by you
can't just rely on glucose stores
so we have this very efficient way to do
it we have a very safe uh Depot of
subcutaneous fat where we can put fat in
it which is excess energy and that's
primarily fatty acids and also excess
glucose can be stored in this form
and we can acquire it as we need it
right so you know when energy stores are
low you go and you you get that or when
energy itself is low you go and acquire
this
the problem comes when you exceed the
capacity of that so the way I describe
it in the book is everybody and this is
largely determined genetically everybody
has a bathtub
some people have a really big bathtub
some people have a really little bathtub
the bathtub is the total capacity of
your uh your fat your fat cells to store
fat
so water goes into the fat cell that's
the food you're eating there's a little
drain at the bottom which is all the
energy you're expending and that's
coming out and therefore the energy in
less the energy out determines the
balance of water in the tub
if you're getting fatter the water is
rising in the bathtub
at some point
the water gets to the lip of the tub you
have now exceeded your capacity for safe
storage of fat or in this case safe
storage of water
what happens next is the water spills
over
now it's gone from being totally
physiologically normal to total chaos
just as if water's filled over your
bathtub it would be total chaos right it
would ruin your house
and the question is where does that fat
go once it spills over
and it's where it goes that causes all
of the problems we're talking about when
it goes into the muscle it impairs the
muscle's ability to sense insulin and
create the glucose transporter to bring
in glucose that's the sin quanon of
insulin resistance when it goes into the
liver it creates inflammation which can
ultimately lead to cirrhosis and liver
failure when it goes into the pancreas
it secretes cytokines that impair the
beta cells which produce insulin which
exacerbates the insulin resistance
problem
when it surrounds your organs as what we
call visceral fat it releases
inflammatory cytokines that lead to
cardiovascular disease
disproportionately
so again all of these things are
happening not because we're getting
fatter in the right place I.E water in
the bathtub but because we're getting
fatter in the wrong place and this is
another example of which it doesn't take
a lot of fat to spill over if a person
has
20 kilograms of fat in their fat cells
it causes no issue it's the two kilos
that have spilled out into all those
other organs that are driving all the
damage
yeah I read two this is another example
of the dangers
and sometimes benefits of the things
that you repeat every day I read at some
point a while back that the Obesity
epidemic
such as it is
could be regarded as being caused by the
additional consumption of one soft drink
a day what non-diet soft drink obviously
because of course you do there's a lot
of sugar eight teaspoons which is four
times as much as you have in your blood
if you're diabetic
but you're doing it every day now and so
that
is hard on the systems that use insulin
to process sugar but it also puts this
Demand on your body to to deal with the
excess glucose how is that glucose
converted to or stored in fat what's
that mechanism so it's called the
technical name is is uh de novo
lipogenesis lipogenesis making fact de
novo from scratch so the liver can turn
the liver is an amazing organ by the way
it's just if we're going to give a shout
out to any organ in the body it might
have to be the liver it's just an unsung
hero it doesn't get the attention it
deserves to put just to go back to one
other thing this whole teaspoon of
glucose in your bloodstream if that
number gets to half a teaspoon you'll
die
your brain won't have enough glucose but
yet you're churning through that at a
rate of a teaspoon every couple of
minutes
what's responsible for that titration
the liver
never stops right so
um one of the other things that the
liver does miraculously is it has the
ability to turn fat into glucose it has
a pardon me it has the ability to turn
glucose into fat and it has the ability
to turn protein into glucose so it can
also change the orientation of molecules
and so the process of turning glucose
into fat is basically an exercise in
Breaking glucose which is a six carbon
molecule down into two carbon chunks and
then joining them in a long fatty acid
chain we would much rather store energy
in fat it's the most efficient uh
chemical molecule in which to store
energy all the energy of course in our
body is in the form of chemical energy
stored in the bonds carbon to carbon and
carbon to hydrogen and a fat is the most
efficient vehicle to do that so we would
much rather actually store energy as fat
than in glucose and we don't store that
much as glucose
okay
so let me
step sideways here for a moment I'd like
to talk about
the food pyramid with you and so I'm
going to lay a little bit out about my
understanding of the food pyramid and
how it came about and then we could talk
about the standard Western diet and its
relationship to insulin resistance and
obesity
so
my understanding is that the food
pyramid was actually
produced by not by scientists or by MDS
although there were some MDS
who were Consulting who were mostly
ignored but by the Department of
Agriculture
and it was a marketing scheme
essentially and that the consequence of
the marketing scheme was that people
were enticed and convinced to rely
primarily on carbohydrates for their
nutritional
necessities and perhaps carbohydrates at
far too excess at a level now
carbohydrates are transmuted into
glucose during metabolism and we eat way
more carbohydrates than we need to
produce the amount of glucose that we
need now people have been getting fatter
in a catastrophic way for about four or
five decades and that's really
in those small parts since the
introduction of the food pyramid now I
do understand that part of the reason
the Department of Agriculture did this
was because carbohydrates and this was
particularly true of corn syrup do
provide a very inexpensive source of
calories and if you're dirt poor and you
don't have enough to eat I mean just
getting enough calories period is of
vital importance not everybody can
afford steak for example or or or or
more expensive foods of that type but
virtually everyone pour an odd in the
West can afford basic carbohydrates but
now we're in this situ but having said
that I also have red and I think it's
valid that there was early evidence that
this heavy carbohydrate-loaded diet that
was being prescribed was going to
increase obesity and diabetes which is
done in at a level that makes the
pandemic epidemic look like absolutely
nothing and and this is still being
pushed forward by people who are
hypothetically on the nutritional front
so two questions what's your
understanding to get the derivation of
the food pyramid and what do you think
about its recommendations for the
typical diet
so I think before getting to that
there's a broader point I want to touch
on that you just sort of alluded to
which is what is the system optimizing
for so in the book I talk about the
standard American diet which I forever
abbreviate is this sad
and the standard American diet is
effectively with or without food pyramid
the standard American diet is what is
killing people and
um so the question is where did the
standard American diet come from the
standard American diet was nothing more
than the solution to a business problem
so the business problem was we need
something where we can produce lots of
food so you had to have this quantity
issue right so that gets to part of the
problem right we have too many people at
the time who are undernourished we can't
have that anymore everyone needs to be
adequately nourished so we need scale
the next thing is exactly your point it
can't cost too much so we have to be
able to do it at scale and it has to be
cheap
the third question or problem statement
was it has to be non-perishable and
portable
right so you can't have abundant food if
it needs to be consumed
10 minutes after it's made so it has to
be sort of non-perishable
um the third sorry the fourth and final
parameter I guess there would be it has
to taste really good we have to make
food very palatable this again is just
part of a business and marketing
strategy
and what I argue I guess is that the
solution to those four things is what we
have today like we when you when you
walk through a grocery store all you're
looking at is the solution space to a
problem statement called those four
questions and it's called the standard
American diet
now with or without a pyramid I'm gonna
just argue that 95 of people if they go
through life eating the standard
American diet with no attention to how
much of it they eat or maybe certain
things in it that they shouldn't eat are
going to be unhealthy there just aren't
that many people that have the genes to
avoid the deleterious consequences of
the standard American diet left
unchecked
and therefore right yeah
well so that was the least
conspiratorial account of the origin of
the American well I mean I've heard it
that's fine yeah that's perfectly
appropriate I mean I do think that
we could give the devil is due and say
the consequences that we have today of
this epidemic of obesity was in fact the
consequence of solving a problem too
effectively I mean the middle of
supermarkets the outside edges of
supermarkets don't contain generally
highly processed carbohydrates let's say
but the center does and they are cheap
and they are delicious and they are
easily provided and they are portable
and they aren't and and so
that did solve the the problem of under
nutrition on the pure caloric front so
we're victims of our own success in that
sense and I suppose it's it's perfectly
reasonable to dispense with the
you know the accusations that the food
pyramid was nothing but a marketing
scheme because it did have to solve
these four problems that you described
and did so
yeah I mean I think what I I certainly
don't want to give the food industry a
pass I mean we could we can certainly
delve into that which is to say there's
no question that data have been
suppressed right there's no question
that
um we're not having an honest discussion
about the following so are all calories
created equal from an energy balance
standpoint sure at an ISO caloric level
if I give you a thousand calories of
Coca-Cola versus a thousand calories of
baked potatoes versus a thousand
calories of steak it will have the same
impact on your energy balance
but it won't have the same impact on
your appetite and your ability to
subsequently eat I mean to me that's
that's the most
um I think probably offensive aspect of
where the food industry has failed right
so the food industry didn't set out to
kill people any more than the tobacco
industry did where these people are
effectively liable is in that they're
not honest about the discussion until
you know it becomes too late and the
reality of it is junk food I think
hijacks your normal appetite centers
and I know people who are very good at
working within those confines so I know
people who can eat junk food in small
amounts and continue to eat nutritious
food and stay in over overall energy
balance they can track their calories
perfectly and they can have a couple of
Oreos and some ice cream here and there
and drink your soda here and there and
they're all fine
what I can just tell you clinically
taking care of actual people who are not
robots
on average more people than not struggle
with that and with the introduction of
these very hyper palatable foods that
kind of hijack your appetite uh it tends
to produce overeating
and ultimately that's the problem at
hand here when people overeat from
whichever part of the pyramid they're
going to overeat from we're going to get
down that whole Cascade we just spoke
about
it just so happens that I think the
things at the bottom of the pyramid are
the things that are making it
easier for you to be disconnected from
the true driver of appetite and there
are lots of hypotheses here right there
are some hypotheses that we are kind of
hardwired to get a certain amount of
nutrient value and as the nutrient value
of our food deteriorates
we have to eat more food we have to eat
more calories to get the certain
nutrient density there are people who
argue we're we're hardwired to get a
certain amount of protein
and as we're diluting protein content in
food we're eating more calories to get
food in other words and by the way I
don't think any one of these
particularly is necessarily the
explanation my guess is it could be a
lot of the above but it's probably the
case that we you know we are
opportunistic omnivores right we grew up
you know we we evolved eating pretty
much anything we could but we didn't eat
that much of it because we didn't really
have that much of it and we were wildly
active
when you eliminate those two
consequences being opportunistic
omnivores is not working for most of us
we have to be more selective uh to push
back against the amazing success of our
civilization
yeah well it is a remarkable thing that
you can walk into your local Starbucks
and there's one on every corner and get
an 850 calorie muffin for for
essentially nothing and that it is
delicious and that it is addictive and
it is a Hallmark of a certain kind of
success I'm going to go sideways here
for a minute and because I have
something I suppose that's slightly more
on the personal side to ask you about so
as you may or may not know my daughter
was very ill with a plethora of
immunological problems including very
serious juvenile arthritis and that was
it just about killed her
it did destroy two of her joints and she
had another 38 that were affected and so
she was always in a lot of pain and we I
looked into the role the diet played in
arthritis through the scientific
literature for a couple of years and
found two things and and they were
somewhat contradictory and one was that
there was no real evidence that any
specific elements of diet had been
linked to juvenile arthritis
specifically but
and this was a major but
if people who are arthritic fasted
completely then there are arthritic
symptoms often disappeared
and so I thought that had something to
do with the consequences of fasting
but then my daughter started to play and
my wife as well very intensely with the
diet we went to a nutritionist who
recommended Elimination Diet at one
point because she did notice that she
would react to strawberries and oranges
we could that and within a day her
thumbs would swell her toes would swell
it so we knew there was some things she
was eating we had her tested for
immunological reaction to food but when
we tested her she showed a hyper
reaction to virtually everything they
tested her for and we concluded at that
point well there's no damn way she could
be reacting to everything she's eating
well she went on this Elimination Diet
and showed a bit of reduction in symptom
but the Elimination Diet made no sense
like there was no Rhyme or Reason to
what you could eat and what you couldn't
eat and so she started to experiment
with more restricted diets and
eventually settled on discovered that if
she only ate beef and it turns out for
her it has to be beef that isn't aged
then all of her immunological symptoms
disappeared
and then my wife and I started playing
with that diet and so I've only been
eating meat for beef fundamentally for
almost five years now
and I've talked to hundreds of people
and we've had messages from thousands of
people showing that this is first of all
radically effective as a weight loss
strategy and also seems to produce
remarkable effects on the
General disease symptom front back in
November of 2021 there was a study
published by a Harvard Group which
wasn't a perfect study because it was
retrospective self-report but they
followed 20 they assessed 24 2500 people
who had been on a carnivore diet for six
months and showed something
approximating a 90 percent reduction in
all disease symptoms and it was the only
scientific paper I ever read where the
surprise of the researchers was palpable
between the lines in the in the
scientific writing because you know in a
scientific article all that emotion
negative or positive is pretty much
ironed out but these people were so
shocked by what they found that it
couldn't help leaking into the document
and so
well this has been quite surprising to
me because I never imagined in my
wildest dreams number one that you could
just live on me number and number two
that it would have such a salutary
effect so for me a guy lost 52 pounds in
seven months
I went from 212 pounds to 165 which is
exactly what I weighed when I was 23 and
I've maintained that weight since I
could put on muscle mass with no problem
even though I'm 62. I had a host of
inflammatory conditions some of which
were quite serious including peripheral
uveitis which sometimes blinds people in
my right eye and it disappeared
completely along with psoriasis and
gastric reflux disorder and
interestingly enough
um gum disease which is technically
incurable which is linked to
cardiovascular degeneration and which
has gone away 100 percent in my case
according to multiple measures that my
dentists have taken and so when I've
talked to many people who've lost like a
hundred pounds in a year you know
because they come to my talks and who
are just beside themselves so to speak
as a consequence of experimenting with
this diet so well so that's the story
it's very strange I don't talk about it
that much because I'm not a nutritionist
and because I'm still shell-shocked by
it but I'll tell you it's something to
be 60 and to have the same essential
body morphology that I had when I was 23
and that had all disappeared for me in
my early 50s
yeah you're not the first person I've
heard this story from Jordan and I have
to be honest with you I just don't know
how to explain it
um the weight loss by the way is not the
harder part to explain right so the more
restrictive any diet is the more one
loses weight on average right so I it
wouldn't surprise me if we put a person
on the all potato diet if they would
lose weight whereas if you put somebody
on the no lettuce diet nobody's going to
lose an ounce so more restrictive diets
ketogenic diets which are not as
restrictive as what you're doing are
also very effective for weight loss by
the way so is a zero fat diet now it's a
unpalatable diet and I don't think it's
particularly healthy diet when you sort
of start restricting fat that much
the more interesting question to me is
and you know and I can certainly
understand if you would say I have no
desire to experiment further by
introducing other elements to see if I
can preserve this phenotype but the most
interesting question to me is
what are the other Foods out there that
you might be able to consume or in the
case of your daughter right like is it
I'm obviously interested in that too but
I what I have found because I have now
and then tried to eat carbohydrates what
I have found is that if I eat any of
them I start to Crave them intensely if
I don't eat them at all
I they don't bother me assuming and this
goes to the calorie restriction issue
um
one of the ways of maintaining yourself
on a keto diet or a carnivore diet let's
say is to make sure you're never hungry
and I eat a lot of meat and a lot of
high fat meat and so I'm never hungry
and I don't think that I'm calorie
restricted at all because you know I can
eat all the Tomahawk Steak sometimes in
one sitting which is about 35 ounces of
meat I never get hungry and I eat high
fat carnivore snacks too
what I found is as long as I'm never
hungry then I I'm not inclined to cheat
but if I do try something like an
introduction of carbohydrates first of
all some of my symptoms come back right
away like the gerds and I start craving
like mad
so well so that's it is is that is it
all carbohydrates or
um like for example if you introduce
vegetables non-starchy vegetables how
what happens both symptom wise and
craving wise
yeah well for a while I was eating
nothing but meat and greens
but I still had some residual symptoms
my wife has a host of immunological
problems that are somewhat low level
and I have a different host and Michaela
seemed to get all of them
and so you know maybe we're absurdly
sensitive for reasons that wouldn't be
true of other people but it's definitely
the case that I do better and believe me
this isn't something I particularly want
it is the case that I do better if I
just stick to beef now could I have pork
and chicken
um I had a very terrible boat of ill
health and I'm disinclined to do a lot
of experimentation although I'll
probably try again in the future
sometime but I do know that beef Works
we've been hypothesizing internally in
our family for what it's worth is that
the reason that beef works and that
other ruminant animals bison so forth uh
um lamb goat is because
they're they they process what they eat
through so many stomachs that by the
time it is actually turned into meat
there's pretty much nothing else there
so it's it's a very purified form of
nutritional uh uh very well a very
purified form of food now like I said
that's anecdotal and this is partly why
I don't talk about it but but I can tell
you after you've talked to a thousand
people who tell you the same anecdote
you don't have an anecdote anymore you
have a hypothesis and it's really quite
something seeing these people who show
me pictures of what they looked like a
year ago and you know they were carrying
around an extra person with them and
they're still Shell Shocked by the
transformation you know because it's
really something to lose say 150 pounds
in a year
and so well
um I don't know what to make of that I
do know that it's been
the diet has actually been rejuvenating
for my wife and I like its effect on
muscle tone has to be seen to be
believed and that's true even though
both of us are 60. like my wife is in
better shape from a musculature
perspective now at 63 than she was when
she was 40 and she was a very physically
fit person who was exercising constantly
and who was in pretty damn good shape
and to see that reverse rather than just
you know stop deteriorating I don't
really know what to make of it
I would love it to be studied
prospectively I'm I'm very curious as to
what's going on in particular with with
that I mean there are there are lots of
data out there showing the efficacy of a
ketogenic diet in the amelioration of
type 2 diabetes
um I I do think I mean look when it
comes to type 2 diabetes any amount of
weight loss is going to produce a
benefit but it seems that a ketogenic
diet has the easiest
um
compliance and uh there might be
something to the fact that it's kind of
removing the thing of which there is an
excess right by by at least taking away
the thing that is in most excess uh it's
easier to kick start that a fast of
course is also a great way to kick start
that right something about taking away
taking glycogen levels down in the liver
and the muscle makes this easier
well that the advantage too of the diet
the carnivore diet in particular is
because you can eat as much as you want
it's actually not a diet you know the
problem with diets is that they require
privation and they require almost
continual privation and then they also
tend to produce a yo-yo effect and
that's partly because if you get in a
fight with your hypothalamus which
drives hunger you're going to lose
because it's there to make damn sure you
don't starve and the probability that
you can override it for any length of
time
but it's very very low and that probably
varies from person to person for all
sorts of reasons but you don't want to
get into scrap with your lower level
motivational systems now you know if I
ever start to crave a banana split for
example I can just eat another five or
six ounces of steak and then I don't
care it's not like it wouldn't taste
good you know but it doesn't preoccupy
me the way it would if I was hungry I've
really noticed this when I go into
grocery stores because if I go into a
grocery store after having consumed
enough meat then the provision of this
infinite display of delicious foods
really doesn't affect me much but boy if
I ever go into a grocery store when I'm
hungry that's quite the pain in the neck
because everything's delightful and
tempting you know so the fact that you
can eat enough or even as much as you
want on a keto or carnivore diet does
seem to distinguish it in some ways from
the diets that depend more particularly
on mere calorie restriction
although I've seen a subset of people on
ketogenic diets who gain weight so they
somehow are eating past their necessary
uh their their their energy Point
um I was on a ketogenic diet for three
years actually I used to write about in
fact when I started blogging in
2010 2011 uh it was basically to I was
mostly talking about nutrition and for
three years minus one day I thought my
wife's birthday one one day and that
three years I had seven pieces of
dessert but minus that one day I was in
a state of ketosis for three years
um and yeah in many ways that was the
poster child for it like it the the
efficacy in me was out of this world
um what did it do for you
oh I mean I lost 40 pounds I you know
was probably I mean just for my body
composition standpoint was you know by
dexa which is the gold standard about
seven and a half percent body fat every
metric of uh every biomarker you could
measure or possibly care about was in
the you know
even by my standards which are not to
consider what's optimal but to consider
what's exceptional everything was great
uh even things that historically people
think you can't do on a ketogenic diet
like lots of intense exercise
uh certainly initially I couldn't do
much of that but within about
six months I had regained much of my
exercise ability and by 18 months I I
had certainly no discernible reduction
in extreme exercise performance again I
don't have the counter factual You could
argue that that's still lesser than what
it would have been at an opportunity
right but you know
some people sometimes say well Peter why
aren't you on the ketogenic diet anymore
why did you stop in 2014 uh it largely
came down to I think just not wanting to
be restrictive anymore and uh wanting to
kind of you know as my at the time
daughter was getting a little bit older
it was you know sort of wanting to enjoy
more of the foods that I was was
limiting but the reality of it is like I
don't uh you know I'm certainly not as
lean as I was when I was on that diet
yeah yeah yeah well the other thing I
noticed this is also very cool and it's
very important to me personally so I
noticed that as I got older my ability
to concentrate when I was reading was
deteriorating so when I was 25 30
when if I picked up a book and read it I
would
shut everything else out and I would
remember concentrate on focus on and
tend to what I was reading
read every word and understand it with
no problem but that started to
deteriorate as I got older and I noticed
that it took an increasing amount of
effort to shut everything off and that
instead of reading as deeply as I was I
was sort of glancing afterwards
and when I started this carnivore diet
that reversed and I can now I think I
actually think this is true I think I
can read faster and more efficiently
than I could when I was in my 20s and I
was pretty good at it when I was in my
20s and so the other thing that I've
noticed too is that I don't have periods
of time this was quite a problem for me
and it might have had something to do
with my immunological problems is that I
would get
hypoglycemic and lose the ability to
concentrate and get what do they call it
hangry you know hungry and angry and
irritable and that would happen several
times a day probably because I was
working too much but in any case that is
gone completely
and I really don't miss it you know I
wake up in the morning with a stable
mood and my mood doesn't very much
throughout the day I'm also much more
stress tolerant and able to re bounce
back from stressors faster and in terms
of uh endurance
you know there were lots of times over
the last three years when I was walking
9 to 12 miles a day on a carnivore diet
now I wasn't running you know but my
experience is that I'm stronger and I
have more stamina than I did 10 years
ago
and that's quite something given that
I'm now 62. that's a good direction you
know it's one thing like I said it's one
thing to Halt the aging process but it's
another thing entirely
to see it start to reverse and so you
know we don't know anything about a
straight carnivore diet to very little
and no one has done a prospective study
it's one that I'm actually thinking
about setting up funding for if I can
find researchers who are interested
because um there's something there and
it was certainly established by that
initial study at Harvard
so if you know anyone who's interested
in doing that you could always hook them
up with me sure I it's some folks there
are some folks that come to mind
actually
okay okay all right so do you want to
talk a little bit about the other more
common diseases that you deal with in
the book you talk about heart disease
we've touched on heart disease you talk
about cancer
um
neurological degeneration Alzheimer's
for example let's walk through that
domain a little bit if if that would be
okay with you sure words like to start
um let's start with cancer
everyone's favorite
yeah I I think um you know cancer is the
second leading cause of death uh in in
the United States and globally
um of the what I describe as these four
horsemen of death uh cardiovascular
disease cancer neurodegenerative disease
and the metabolic diseases that we've
already talked about
um cancer hits its peak first so the
other diseases rise monotonically with
aging
cancer actually peaks in late middle age
so so cancer would be the leading cause
of chronic death uh or CR you know
chronic diseases of Aging uh in the 40s
and 50s and 60s before it's supplanted
by cardiovascular disease and even
neurogenerative disease
um
if you go back to the year I was born
and you ask the question what is the
probability that a person with
metastatic cancer I.E cancer that has
spread from its
primary organ to a distant organ
what's the probability they're going to
be alive in 10 years
the answer was zero percent nobody was
going to survive that
today the answer is about five percent
maybe a little bit higher but it's it's
really not been an enormous uh source of
success so so let's talk about what the
bright spots are the bright spots are
leukemias lymphomas testicular cancer
these are areas where there has been
great progress and your survival today
is so much higher than it was 50 years
ago
when you talk about the big Killers
though which are lung cancer prostate
cancer breast cancer colon cancer
pancreatic cancer those are the top five
causes of cancer death
median survival the length of time you
survive has increased by as much as a
year if not more but overall survival
has not this is a very important thing
to understand the risk of being dead in
10 years if that cancer has spread is
the same as it was 50 years ago
do you suppose that's a possible
consequence of the presence of cancer
being a marker for like cumulative
systemic failure
is that it it's if there's cancer
somewhere is it an indicator that many
things have gone wrong at many levels
and so even if you treat the cancer the
probability that that's going to be
life-saving is quite low or is it just a
consequence of the tremendous capacity
of metastatic cancers to spread
so there's a couple of things going on
for cancer to take place
um so so
the first critical step of a cancer is a
genetic mutation has to happen
and largely speaking these fall into two
categories there are genes that are uh
promoting cancer growth and then there
are genes that suppress cancer growth so
anytime you get mutations in one of
those systems it becomes oncogenic
now fortunately when a cell becomes
cancerous
it starts to let out clues that it is
not a normal cell so when a breast cell
goes from being a normal mammary cell to
a cancerous mammary cell
it starts to look a little bit different
and the immune system our immune system
the cellular immune system
is very good at patrolling the body
for signs of things that are not self
that's what it's programmed to do so the
it's a very beautiful way to think about
it but the immune system is not
programmed to recognize bad things it's
it's programmed to recognize things that
are not self
this is done through something called
thymic selection when we're you know
basically very young
so uh and by the way too much of that
problem leads to autoimmunity so that
you know you can think about this
through your own personal story right
which is there's a very fine balance
here too much of knowing what is you
know uh not self and too little of that
are both equally bad
so there are always some cells that
recognize this in fact Steve Rosenberg
who I did my postdoc with uh recently
published some really amazing data which
I I find one of the most staggering
statistics of all of cancer and also one
of the most hopeful
which is that 80 percent of epithelial
tumors epithelial tumors are the ones
that kill people that's the solid organ
stuff the breast colon prostate Etc 80
of those tumors produce what are called
novel neoantigens meaning they produce
peptides small proteins that are not
self and are recognized by the immune
system as not self
the problem is the reason those 80
percent of patients don't go into
spontaneous remission is they can't
mount a strong enough immune response to
that
so it's sort of like having some immune
cells that recognize you have a virus
but not enough that they can actually
kill the virus and ultimately the virus
kills them
to your broader question which is
if you're listening to this what do you
do about it
it starts to me with what are the two
most clear environmental triggers of
cancer and how do you avoid them and
then secondly what's the rest of your
strategy so
um when it comes to heart disease and
neurodegenerative disease and metabolic
disease which are the other three
Horsemen
our ability to incorporate prevention is
so significant that it plays The Lion's
Share of our strategy because we have
such an understanding of the risk
factors for Alzheimer's disease the risk
factors for metabolic disease and the
risk factors for heart disease your
prevention strategy is not doing those
25 things
or minimizing how much you're doing
those things with cancer there's really
just two big things
smoking and obesity slash insulin
resistance
now the literature would just say
obesity but I add insulin resistance
because I think that the literature is
to blunt a tool to tease out what's
really going on and what's really
driving it I think is the inflammatory
and
um metabolic I.E the high growth factors
such as insulin that are coming with
most but not all cases of obesity so
what we really want to avoid is being
metabolically unhealthy and smoking
but here's the thing so that insulin
insulin overproduction also in your
opinion facilitates cancer
origination or or or or or propagation
cancer has I don't think yeah I think
it's a propagation issue not an
initiation yeah right and we know that
because there are more than 20 cancers
whose risk for whom your risk goes up by
about a 2X Factor if you're obese
and I think the only thing that makes
sense in that sense in understanding
that observation is the inflammatory and
pro-growth environment that that is in
that individual so do we want to avoid
that absolutely but but my point is
there are think of how many people who
are non-smokers who are metabolically
healthy who still get cancer that's a
very long list of people so I wouldn't
be able to hang my hat on this as well
my anti-cancer strategy is not smoking
and being metabolically healthy and
hoping that that's enough we have to
have another tool in this toolkit and
that tool is a very controversial one
but nevertheless I think it's important
and it's very aggressive screening
and the reason for this is another
observation that I don't think gets
enough attention which is when you
consider
two different individuals with the same
cancer but at different stages who are
treated with the exact same treatment
their survivals are very different so if
you take a person with stage four colon
cancer which means the cancer has spread
to say the liver and you treat them with
the same cocktail of drugs that you give
a person at stage three cancer where
it's just spread from the colon to the
lymph nodes but no further at least to
the naked eye
the survival for the people for whom it
spread to the liver is zero percent at
ten years whereas the ones to the lymph
nodes it's going to be about 60 to 65
percent at the same period of time
a fundamental difference they're getting
the same treatment so
it's the difference between treating
somebody when they have a billion Cells
versus a hundred billion or a trillion
cells
and the problem is that there's more
mutational burden the more cancer you
have you have more Escape mechanisms for
the cancer that's probably the best
explanation for it
all of the and we could do this analysis
for all other types of cancer like
breast cancer Etc what it points to is
early detection is essential
so what does that mean practically what
what do people have to do with their
physicians in order to ensure that
they're being optimally screened
for for the possibility of cancer and at
what age does that start to become more
crucial it's very difficult for me to
provide a blanket statement because even
when I'm talking about this with my
patients I have a long discussion with
them about the challenges of doing this
so let's put aside the obvious challenge
which is cost none of the advanced types
of screening
um or working at the advanced rate are
going to be covered by insurance right
so in the United States uh it's recently
been changed to 45 from 50 for the
initial colonoscopy that's an excellent
step in the right direction I still
think it's about five years too late I
think even for a person without a family
history of colon cancer I would
recommend and at least for our patients
would recommend screening at to begin at
40 instead of 45.
the frequency with which it's not
cheaper it's not cheaper for the
insurance companies to screen than it is
to pay for advanced cancer treatment in
Hopeless cases oh it certainly is but
you're uh you're confounding something
which is at least in the Canadian Health
Care system that might make more sense
because the government owns the risk for
life
so at least if I don't and I can't you
know despite the fact that I grew up in
Toronto I can't really speak to the
Canadian Health Care system with any
Authority but at least that's something
Canada has going for it which is when
you're 40 getting a colonoscopy or when
you're 50 getting a colonoscopy that
catches a little polyp that costs
nothing to remove and prevent it from
going to cancer
um you still own that life and that risk
10 years later in the U.S that's not the
case in the U.S people are never really
owned from a risk perspective by one
entity for very long so there's much
much less incentive in our system
unfortunately to truly invest in
prevention and that's a you know if we
were to talk about the structural
problems of the U.S health care System
uh that might be the single most
important one
well the other problem on the prevention
front you know is that prevention isn't
dramatic because you get no credit for
for preventing a hundred things that
don't happen
you know if you cure something that's
pretty dramatic because someone's ill
and you cure them and the fact that
they're no longer real is self-evident
but if you stop something cold in its
tracks all that happens is that people
pay attention to other
problems and other let's say more uh
showy and noticeable cures and so it's
not only hard to fund prevention it's
also hard to Market it right because you
can't give credit to the people who've
Managed IT and so that's a that's a big
structural problem like it seems one of
the logical conclusions from our
conversation was that
it would have been a much better
investment on the government side and on
the social side to have put a fair chunk
of the money that was spent on cancer
treatment into
prevention of the entire range of
diseases that we've been discussing and
with with primarily with the focus
likely on what on obesity
as the number one is it is it I think I
think that's the number one concern
across all these classes well clearly
generative disease uh oh yes yes if
you're gonna say well it's metabolic
disease right so obesity is just a proxy
for that but yes metabolic disease would
be the you know one that feeds and
amplifies all the others
um but there are other things that we
haven't explored like I don't think we
have done a decent job remotely of
understanding going just going back to
cancer what the impact is of other
environmental toxins in cancer and the
reason I think it's so important in
cancer to look at this is because
smoking and obesity only explain so much
of it so in other words the I can't tell
you what the number is but it's knowable
and it's large the number of people who
get cancer who are neither smokers nor
have obesity or insulin resistance and
so there's still a big fraction of
people for whom something else is
driving their cancer and I suspect there
are other environmental toxins whether
they be pesticides whether they be uh
you know chemicals in the ground like
there are other things out there that
might not produce a large enough signal
to show up either because of their
ubiquity or because the direct impact is
not as large and the fact that we don't
know this to me is problematic
right so that's another variant in some
ways of prevention to identify
additional mutagenic agents we already
know about that on the smoking front but
and then to take them out of the
environment so that the diseases don't
occur to begin with let's switch by the
way I do I do want to I do want to say
one thing about what you said Jordan
that is very true and there's no disease
for which it's more tragic than with the
the dementing diseases specifically
Alzheimer's disease so if you want to
look at the amount of research that's
gone into treatment versus prevention
it's in dollars spent
you'd need scientific notation to tell
you what that ratio is like it's
99.999999999 to .000 it's not even close
and the net result has been abysmal
so there is no disease for which we have
less to show for the work that's gone
into it than Alzheimer's disease
right we have a couple of improved drugs
the other
go ahead yeah we have a couple of
approved drugs that have virtually no
efficacy at best they might slow the
rate of progression zero reversal and
yet I think it's Crystal Clear that your
trajectory towards Alzheimer's disease
is probably much more malleable than
your trajectory towards cancer and we
should have a very clear Playbook on
what that looks like given how difficult
it is to treat that disease once it's
present
right well I guess the other problem on
the prevention front is that it's it's
more difficult to monetize prevention
it's quite straightforward to monetize
drugs to cure or to not cure as long as
they're administered to enough people
but how do you monetize prevention and
and people might say well everything
can't be about money it's like well
without money you can't Market it
without marketing you can't communicate
and so there's all sorts of obstacles
that are quite subtle in the way of
mounting an effective prevention
campaign
and but it does it certainly seems if
you let's let's close with two questions
one might be
if you could
seize control of Public Health spending
on the research and public policy front
where would you devote the bulk of
resources now I mean
like one example might be well you know
would we start a campaign to reduce the
consumption of carbohydrate especially
sugar but but but we talked about other
elements of prevention as well if we're
going to spend our money research money
in our Public Health money efficiently
and get the most bang for the buck where
do you think we should spend it and what
evidence do you have to support that
it's really hard to say because this is
just as much a behavioral question as it
is a scientific or medical question
again the numbers point back to exercise
Jordan there's no ambiguity about that
right you're going to get more benefit
in a person's health if you get their
VO2 max High you put lots of muscle mass
on them and you create a high degree of
strength and that's going to be true for
men women young old it doesn't matter
there is no exception to this Rule and
therefore
um you know
I would put most of my resources from a
public health standpoint into how do you
do that how do you make exercise
something that is interwoven from
preschool onward at a level that is
truly efficacious and that's going to
not just mean getting people to exercise
it's going to be figuring out ways to
change the environment that supports
being active more often so that you're
being active and not even when you're
not exercising but it's also going to
involve understanding that everybody's
different there are some people who hate
exercise and what do you need to do to
make it more enjoyable for those people
what kind of financial incentives do you
put in place for people to exercise
because I really do believe carrots can
be more effective than sticks here and
uh you know simply you know I mean we
talk people are sitting here talking
about you know Universal basic income as
a potential way to alleviate some of the
societal problems well if we're going to
be paying people maybe paying them to
exercise
um and providing you know a way for for
a really good in incentive around this
because it's gonna obviously save cost
but I think more importantly improve the
quality of a person's life no individual
cares about the cost right because
they're not bearing the cost so that's a
the arguments around that I don't think
matter I think the only thing that
matters is can we have you do something
that's going to improve the quality of
your life
wonder wonder what would happen if we
took kids out for a 15-minute walk every
morning as part of the school curriculum
and made that habitual you know it'd be
good for the kids too because they might
be able to sit down and attend a bit
more if they actually had a bit of
exercise before they were required to
sit and do nothing for six hours so you
know to build to start building those
habits of activity uh in youth so that
they I mean I would get I would get rid
of chairs I would get rid of chairs in
schools every kid would have a standing
desk I mean there's sitting is just a
it's not a particularly productive thing
in the position we do it in right I mean
sitting in a squatted position is fine
uh but this the angle that we're sitting
at is really it's it's it's not
conducive to the great biomechanics
later in life so we you know if you
watch a child your kids are probably too
old now but mine are not I can see the
change in body mechanics as they go
through more and more time in chairs and
it's true of adults oh right well well
obviously what we're doing in schools is
training people to be sedentary yeah
obviously I mean that might be the most
fundamental impact of the education
system you know I read an interesting
book years ago called systematics by a
man named John Gall and it's a set of
aphorisms about how systems work you
know and one of the aphorisms which I
never forgot was the system does not do
what its name says it does
and so when you analyze the system for
example
one of the reasons I think that
universities get away with charging
tuition fees that are like absolutely
unreasonable by any standard is that you
have a pretty decent chance of meeting
your lifetime mate if you go to
university and so it might be that the
fundamental function of universities is
to Aid in the process of assorted of
mating like systems are very complex and
hypothetically the education system
educates kids but what but it's
fundamental function for all we know
might be turned to turn people into
sedentary and obese adults
because we don't know right we we're not
smart enough to to analyze the behavior
these complex systems let's end with one
final thing
we touched briefly on the issue of
emotional health
and so tell me Tell just tell me your
thoughts on that general what are your
recommendations in outlive in your book
and and how do you how do you associate
the issue of psychological and emotional
health with the well with exercise and
diet for example or any of the other
lifestyle modification processes that
we've discussed
so I think emotional health ties into
this longevity equation in many ways so
you can start at a very extreme end uh
a a low enough state of emotional health
can be a direct threat to your life so
again the most extreme extreme example
of that would be suicide
but if you walk back from suicide we
talk about Paris suicide we talk about
all the different behaviors that people
engage in that are slow suicides I can't
speak to what the statistics are in
Canada but in the United States and I I
suspect you know these more than I do
Jordan uh if if we look at three
categories of deaths of Despair suicide
overdose and alcohol-related death uh so
cirrhosis things like that the deaths of
Despair have been increasing at anywhere
from 10 to 20 percent year on year on
year over the past four or five years
so we just for that's brutal yeah so
just last last year was the first year
that overdose took more than a hundred
thousand lives in the United States
so yeah well you know it's an open
question how many people on the edge of
of depressive collapse were tipped over
that edge by the lockdowns and the
prolonged social isolation and the
increase in fear you know up in Toronto
I still see people and uh in La too it
was quite noticeable I was there
yesterday I still still see people
cowering behind their masks and no you
have to have been made pretty
chronically afraid to still be doing
that and the the uh cost to People's
Health of the fear campaign that drove
that drove the lockdowns we're going to
see that I mean I don't know how that's
contributing to the excess deaths I
think it would be very difficult to say
that those statistics I rattled off
aren't impacted by covid so what's going
to be interesting right is to see how
that plays out going forward
my point of course is that these deaths
of Despair are a very extreme example of
how emotional health impacts longevity
directly right here it's just truncating
lifespan way too soon in fact
um overdose is now the leading cause of
death in the United States for people
aged 10 to 55.
wow wow oh that's terrible so and so so
what do you see on the prevention front
there
or do you have well let's go even one
layer further because I'm sure there's
someone listening to this who says well
look that's not me I don't drink to
excess I would never touch an illicit
drug and I'm in no danger of killing
myself so that that means emotional
health is checked and I would say no not
really because that's just the first
layer let's go one layer deeper I think
the next layer is how many people
because of their relationship with
themselves are unable to self-care
if we're really going to be honest about
it
how often do we engage in
not what would rise to the level of
quote-unquote harmful Behavior but
certainly things that are not in our
best care
eating a little bit too much not
exercising enough not sleeping well you
know engaging in behaviors uh or failing
to engage in healthy behaviors now again
I see this constantly with patients
where
it's not that they don't know what to do
it's not that they don't know that they
should exercise but if you really push
them
they have a negative relationship with
themselves that is preventing them from
taking care of themselves
I would say that the impact on length of
Life there and quality of life is much
bigger than the deaths of Despair but
it's much harder to quantify
so then I'd go even one step further and
say okay well you're not in category one
where you're an immediate threat to your
life because of this emotional uh your
emotional health and you're not even at
the point where you're failing to take
care of yourself
but now you maybe land where
you're you're just not happy your your
relationships suck right you're uh
you're a lousy father you're a lousy
husband you're a lousy parent you know
any of these things
and you're basically living without a
sense of why right you're you're you're
you're not
um you know as Esther perel put it to me
what is the purpose of living longer if
you're unhappy
and I think that that's probably the
biggest circle and and that's to me one
of the most interesting ones here
and again for me personally the the one
I wanted to explore the most in myself
which was uh how much of this obsession
with longevity is about
figuring out how to not die versus
understanding how to live
and so what what have you concluded on
the treatment front in regards to to
that set of problems or the prevention
front let's say
well again it's worth caveating that
everything that I write about in the
book I come to it with some lens of
expertise right I mean it's what I do
for a living it's what I've spent more
than a decade researching uh you know I
can I can speak with some Authority
about cancer and heart disease and
dementia and exercise and nutrition
when it comes to this particular issue I
have no expertise I come at this through
the lens of a patient
and therefore I think everything I say
must be taken with the understanding
that it's somewhat anecdotal
um and therefore needs to be explored
with with professionals who I think can
bring to it for example the expertise
you could bring to it
but I'll tell you what I've learned I've
learned that most people
probably have some degree of unresolved
business in their childhood that has
produced adaptations
and in some cases many of those
adaptations are very good and should
continue but some of those adaptations
are negative
and
that is malleable right so there's
there's kind of this view of Hope which
is
you don't have to throw out the baby
with the bath water you can again in my
case you can take some of those
adaptations which produce you know hard
work discipline all of these things but
you can get rid of some of the negative
ones such as the negative self-talk
um the perfectionism all these other
things that created a very negative
impact on myself and those around me so
this requires very hard work and
unfortunately
um
it's not something that lends itself to
the faint of heart unfortunately at
least in my experience I'd be much more
Curious at your experience
many people need to be at a local Minima
you know not necessarily the rock bottom
but close to a rock bottom to start to
probe those they're like I can't I can
tell you some of the things that I've
learned uh partly as a consequence of
public lecturing and and speaking to
people constantly about how they might
straighten up their life the first thing
I would say is we've run
a series of studies on a set of programs
I designed with my students and my my
previous graduates my graduate
supervisor Robert peel and Daniel
Higgins appeal was my supervisor and
Higgins my student we developed a suite
of exercises
called The self-authoring Suite there at
self-authoring.com
the past authoring program helps you
write an autobiography and clear up that
excess baggage
and the present authoring program helps
you analyze your faults and your virtues
rather programmatically so that you can
start to generate a strategy to rectify
your faults and to capitalize on your
virtues and the future authoring program
which we've studied most intently helps
you develop a vision
for the next five years and if we have
people do the future authoring program
before they enter University if they do
90 minutes of developing a vision 90
minutes that's all no preparation with
no one reviewing what they've written
the probability that they'll drop out
false 50 percent and their grade point
average goes up 35 percent
and it is tied to precisely what you
described is that people need a reason
to live and
I also in this exercise we help people
break down the reasons to live and this
touches on another point that you made
regarding relationships you can't be
healthy psychologically in the absence
of a network of functional relationships
you need a partner you need a family you
need friends you need business
colleagues you have to be nested in a
functional social hierarchy and so we
walk people through this process of
vision development
we asked them what they would like to
have in five years if they could have
what they wanted and needed we asked
them how catastrophic their lives would
be in five years if they let their bad
habits get out of control
that sort of sets the parameters right
don't do this and do this and then we
ask them seven questions
what do you want an intimate
relationship
what do you want in your friendships
what do you want for your job in your
career how are you going to educate
yourself how are you going to take care
of yourself mentally and physically what
are you going to do with your time
outside of work that's productive and
generous how are you going to shoulder
some civic responsibility
uh I think that covers the fundamental
domains those are places that people
generally Find meaning in their lives
and the upshot of all this is that
almost no one has an explicit strategy
for their life and that's a catastrophe
what do they say the people perish
without a vision this is literally the
case and this is precisely what we're
talking about it but it turns out just
as in the case of exercise you said you
can get a walloping Advantage from just
going from zero to three hours going
from no plan at all to a hastily
contrived 90-minute plan well like I
said that has that stops half the kids
from dropping out of University
and so there are there's a large body of
research showing that these sort of
writing exercises to clean up your past
and to structure your future are
salutary on the psychological and the
physiological front so you can imagine
there's a three-prong approach to
to health span right
sufficient exercise
appropriate diet and the development of
something like a comprehensive account
of and vision for your life
yeah and that would be relatively
inexpensive and all things considered
relatively easy to implement
so you never know maybe we'll get smart
enough to move hard in that direction as
a society over the next couple of
decades
so I guess is there anything else you'd
like to tell people before we close
we're going to turn just so everybody's
listening knows we're gonna and watching
we're going to turn to the Daily wire
plus platform
I'm going to talk to Dr Adia for
additional half an hour about the
development of his interest in these
areas over his lifespan that's usually
what I do in in that half an hour period
is there anything else Dr Adia that you
would like to relate to the viewers and
and listeners before we close
no I think I think those are three great
principles there and
um I guess the only final thing I would
say and it kind of ties a little bit
into the last one is there's an exercise
I have my patients do called the
marginal decade exercise
so you write down on a piece of paper
your age so I'm 50 and you draw a line
extending across the page and you tick
off at 10-year increments so 60 70 80
90. and then I do the same exercise for
my kids so I have a 15 year old girl
nine-year-old boy six-year-old boy and I
tick those out at the same 10-year
increments so 25 so the daughter of 25
35 45
Etc and they're lined up okay and then I
start to imagine when they might have
kids so there's a little this is a
little bit of guessing but I start to
put you know grandkid one grandkid two
grandkid three grandkid four okay
and then I go to what is the Actuarial
expectation of my life which is you know
low to mid 80s
and I asked the question what would
another decade buy me
and on one level it doesn't look that
interesting right it's buying me the
difference between being 83 and 93.
but if that 10 years is at a reasonable
high level of function and let's be
clear it's not going to look like it
looks now
but I Define what that function is I
still want to be able to walk up a
flight of stairs I still want to be able
to carry a bag of groceries I still want
to be able to lift my suitcase up
I get I look down and I see what a
difference it is in terms of those
relationships
it's a profound difference in the decade
of that person's life and my ability to
be a part of that life and for them to
be a part of my life
and I say all of that because it's the
why that matters a little bit here right
right right right well you know that
might be part of the Magic Bullet in
relationship to preventions that
well why you should eat junk food is
obvious it's immediately gratifying and
delicious so the wise
a no-brainer
it's the same with abuse of drugs like
cocaine we don't have to explain why
people abuse cocaine we have to explain
why all people don't abuse it 100 of the
time because it immediately activates
the systems to mediate positive emotion
so that's a no-brainer
if you look at the alcohol cessation
literature what you find is quite a
pronounced
multi-decade set of conclusions that
show that if you want to stop drinking
you need a reason you need to find
something to do that's better than
drinking and if you like alcohol
drinking is pretty good it's a highly
social activity it's not that expensive
it's available constantly
it's an anxiolytic it it's uh cycle
motor stimulant for some people it
probably increases opiate response so
it's very rewarding well the problem is
is that it you know it ruins your life
over a multi-decade period and blows
your relationships to bits but if you
don't have a vision of yourself
extending across that span of time then
why the hell should you care and it
might be the same on the exercise and
nutrition front it's like you're not
going to take care of yourself unless
you know you have something useful to do
and I've been talking to people all over
the world about taking responsibility
partly because if you take
responsibility for other people
it improves your relationships and if
you have better relationships well
you're much more resilient and you're
and you have much more of an opportunity
for positive emotion and so
if you take responsibility you have a
long-term vision of yourself as well and
so maybe the psychologists and the
medical doctors can get together and
figure out how to Ally the work on
exercise and nutritional improvement
with motivation and and produce
prevention strategies that people will
actually
follow
partly because they see a reason in
following them you need a reason to make
sacrifice you know
yeah I I think that's the Cure I think
that's the key Point here and I think
that's
that's the part that's the point I'm
trying to make with respect to emotional
health which is if you don't have this
why
we're just not robots that can be
programmed to do all those other things
we have to have a reason and I think
your examples are great ones virtually
everything that is bad for your health
feels much better in the moment so to
say no to that you have to to to offset
the hyperbolic discounting problem of
delayed gratification you must have
something that is stronger than the
immediate hedonic pleasure of either not
exercising eating the wrong thing
staying up too late you pick pick
whatever it is
yeah well you know when I want to have a
banana split which is reasonably often I
think yeah you know but I'm pretty happy
to have uh physiological Constitution
that's a lot more like I I a lot more
like it was when I was 23 than I had
when I was 50.
that's pretty good deal you know and the
value in that I suppose that marginal
decade for example the value and that's
palpable enough so that I think yeah
well it is a sacrifice but
it's probably worth it so that's the
question hey what's what's it worth
making a sacrifice for and it's a
question you have to answer if you're
going to put your life together and put
your health together all right everyone
watching and listening on YouTube thank
you very much for your time and
attention to the Daily wire plus people
for facilitating this conversation
that's much
appreciated I'm here in Boise Idaho
today I'm doing this conversation the
daily wire always finds me a studio and
a studio for my guests
um to the film crew here thank you very
much for flawless experience
um Dr Addy I was very good of you to
talk to me today I wish you the best of
luck without living the book and in your
own life and uh I would also uh
encourage those who are listening to
continue to follow our conversation on
The Daily wire plus platform we will
talk for another half an hour on more
biographical and personal issues thanks
very much everybody thanks Dr Adia it's
good to meet you thank you so much
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com